pouvez-vous dans un premier temps nous
dresser un bilan des actions spécifiques
menées en 2020 et 2021 pour lutter
contre les violences nous indiquer le
montant des dépenses supplémentaires
liées à la mise en place de ces mesures
enfin nous préciser ceux des dispositifs
mis en place qui ont vocation à être
pérennisées
l'actualité de votre ministère concerne
aussi indépendamment des conséquences de
la crise sanitaire le bilan du grenelle
de lutte contre les violences conjugales
ces initiatives avaient été rendue
publique pour des raisons symboliques à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
pour l'élimination de la violence à
l'égard des femmes du 25 25 novembre
2019 à quelques semaines du deuxième
anniversaire de la conclusion de ce
grenelle où nous en sommes nous nous
aimerions également avoir un bilan
précis de l'attribution par département
des places d'hébergement supplémentaires
annoncés dans le cadre du grenelle ainsi
qu'un point sur la montée en charge des
dispositifs prévus dans le cadre du
renforcement de la politique pénale de
lutte contre les violences c'est à dire
les téléphones graves dangers et les
bracelets entier rapprochement plus
précisément de plus comme c'est l'usagé
à cette période de l'année nous
attendons de vous un état des lieux des
dispositions du projet de loi de
finances pour 2022
concernant votre ministère il y à des
batailles qui transforme tout une
société et qui réhausse une nation et je
crois que l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de ces batailles longtemps
enseveli sous l'indifférence collective
ces inégalités insupportables sont
désormais regarder en face par notre
société toute entière est avec
l'intransigeance qu'elle mérite dans ce
contexte comme vous le savez le
président de la république a fait de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la grande cause de son quinquennat et
parce que l'égalité est impossible de
sans éradiquer le fléau des violences le
combat contre les violences faites aux
femmes en constitue le premier pilier et
vous l'avez mentionné à plusieurs
reprises madame résidente parce que ça a
été une étape extrêmement importante
de notre travail et ce travail qui a été
fait sur les violences conjugales avec
le grenelle de violence lancé le 3
septembre 2019 avait cette ambition d'
éradiquer ce fléau des violences
conjugales et intrafamiliales dans notre
pays et l'ensemble des ministères et des
acteurs de l'état ont été mobilisés sur
cette question parce que ces violences
s'opère dans toutes les sphères de notre
société parce que les réponses à offrir
pour les enrayer mobilise une kyrielle
d'acteurs différents aux côtés des
associations
ce combat est par définition un enjeu
interministériel la première fois que
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être auditionnés par
votre délégation le 5 novembre 2020 23
des 46 mesures du grenelle avait été
réalisé et 20 mesures étaient en cours
de réalisation alors où est ce que nous
en sommes à présent je veux commencer
par vous dire que 100% des mesures du
grenelle des violences conjugales ont
été engagés aujourd'hui 35 d'entre elles
sont pleinement réalisées et 11 sont en
cours de réalisation et parmi les
mesures emblématiques qui nous restait à
déployer l'an dernier j'aimerais
notamment m'arrêter sur trois d'entre
elles je pense notamment et vous m'avez
interrogé là-dessus à l'extension des
horaires du 39 19 une mesure ô combien
importante pour les victimes de
violences comme vous le savez le
gouvernement souhaitait initialement
passer par une procédure de marché
public nous avons toutefois entendu les
associations les parlementaires et vous
m'avez interpellé également madame la
présidente et les élus locaux est
également et je crois que nous avons en
tout cas nous avons eu envie de faire
preuve de pragmatisme et de célérité
avec une seule boussole la préoccupation
pour les victimes mais c'est pourquoi le
25 mai dernier j'ai signé la nouvelle
convention pluriannuelle d'objectifs
entre l'état et la fédération nationale
solidarité femmes une première étape
avait été franchie le 28 juin
ça va
nous avions franchi une première étape
le 28 juin puisque les horaires du 39 19
avaient été étendues 24 heures sur 24 du
lundi au vendredi et l'extension sept
jours sur sept a été rendu effectif le
30 août dernier nous avons ainsi tenu
notre engagement du passage à des
horaires 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
pour toute la france dans l'hexagone et
sur les territoires ultramarins cette
demande de longue date est aujourd'hui
une réalité et je voudrais vous partager
quelques chiffres du 28 juin au 24
septembre 2021 ce sont 31 1190 appels
supplémentaires qui ont pu être prise en
charge pendant la nuit par les
écoutantes du 39 19 cette extension se
traduit également par une meilleure
connaissance de la linde écoute des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
n'hésitent plus maintenant a appelé et
je pense aux personnes aphasiques ou aux
personnes malentendantes
en outre il a d'ores et déjà été
constatés en juillet 2021 une
augmentation de 42% des appels provenant
des dom signe que ce numéro est
désormais plus accessible à ces
territoires autrement dit ces nouveaux
créneaux de nuit ont permis à des femmes
extrêmement vulnérables de trouver une
écoute ainsi qu'un soutien psychologique
nécessaire afin d'éviter l'escaladé de
la peur enfin pour répondre à votre
question madame la présidente
l'engagement financier de l'état a
significativement progressé ces
dernières années afin d'assurer
l'extension des horaires du 39 19 le la
subvention du programme 137 à la fnsf
était de 1 million 600 21000 euros en
2018 elle est passée à un million neuf
cent cinquante euros en 2020 et puis
elle se hissera à deux millions cinq
cent cinquante sept mille euros en 2021
la deuxième mesure capitale que je
voudrais souligner et la création de
places d'hébergement d'urgence
supplémentaires pour les victimes c'est
une cin c'est un sujet important qui
revient très régulièrement dans les
interrogations à la suite de l'annoncé
faite à l'occasion du comité
interministériel l égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes du 8 mars 2018 nous
avions prévu de garantir 5000 places
d'hébergement et parce que les demandes
étaient de plus en plus importante parce
que la parole se libère de plus en plus
le gouvernement a souhaité aller encore
plus loin et c'est pourquoi avec
emmanuelle wargon nous avons créé 1000
nouvelles places d'hébergement en 2020
et nous en créons milles supplémentaires
en 2021 portant ainsi le parc total
d'accueil des victimes de violence à
7800 place d'ici la fin de cette année
et cela nous permettra d'augmenter le
nombre de places d'hébergement depuis
2010 est à 60% par ailleurs permettez
moi de souligner que le financement des
nouvelles places de 2021 a été
revalorisé de 30% avec un coup à la
place qui est passé de 25 euros à 35
euros en moyenne sur le territoire
national enfin une autre mesure
importante que nous étions en passe de
concrétiser il y un an lorsque j'étais
ici devant vous c'est la mise en place
de 30 centres de prise en charge des
auteurs de violences la prévention et la
fin du cycle des violences constituent
des enjeux essentiels comme vous le
savez des politiques publiques dans
leurs dimensions sociales judiciaires et
sanitaires et nous avons ainsi pris le
sujet de la récidive et donc des auteurs
à bras le corps il s'agissait d'une
revendication forte des victimes et des
associations qui est ressorti du
grenelle et ce constat s'appuyer aussi
sur des initiatives telles que des
foyers d'accueil comme l'altérité de
besançon où le home des rosati arras à
ce jour 18 centres de prise en charge
ont été ouverts en 2020 et ils sont
opérationnels et les autres le seront
très prochainement avant la fin de cette
année ainsi chaque région est ou sera
pourvue d'au moins un centre et on en
recense 3 dans les grandes régions y
compris sur les territoires ultramarins
ces centres de prise en charge
présentent toutes des actions de
responsabilisation des auteurs et un
accompagnement psychothérapeutique et
médico sociale ainsi que des actions
d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle environ 3000 hommes
ont été reçus par ses centres de prise
en charge depuis leur ouverture et on
sait déjà
qu'il contribue à réduire la récidive
les terribles féminicide de mérignac et
d'ail anges nous ont malheureusement
rappeler que le combat que nous menons
est un combat permanent un combat qui ne
s'arrête jamais pour reprendre les mots
du premier ministre dans ce contexte
après la remise de deux rapports
d'inspection le premier ministre a
décidé de mettre en place six nouvelles
mesures et des moyens supplémentaires
pour mieux protéger les victimes
mieux suivre les auteurs de violences et
mieux coordonner les acteurs engagés à
niveau au niveau national mais aussi au
niveau local
commençons par les téléphones graves
dangers pour mieux protéger les victimes
télé 3000 téléphone graves dangers
seront mis à disposition des
juridictions d'ici le mois de novembre
2021 cela correspond à une augmentation
de 65% par rapport à aujourd'hui et
comme l'a affirmé le premier ministre le
3 septembre dernier nous en mettrons
autant que nécessaire à disposition des
parquets mieux protéger les victimes
c'est aussi renforcer le déploiement des
bracelets anti rapprochement depuis
décembre 2020 le gouvernement en a
déployés 1001 en un plan de renforcement
pour accroître leur recours a été mis en
place et le garde des sceaux a publié
une circulaire pardon une dépêche le 21
mai 2021 à destination des parquets pour
accélérer le déploiement de ces nouveaux
outils
la dépêche du garde des sceaux prévoit
notamment un suivi statistique réguliers
sur les attributions de ces bracelets
dans chaque juridiction et la
désignation d'un référent national et
d'un référent au sein des parquets au 20
septembre 2021 414 bracelet avaient été
prononcées dont 305 actifs cette mesure
comme vous le savez peut-être
a déjà fait ses preuves en espagne et
elle constitue une étape importante dans
notre combat contre les violences et si
nous avons avancé depuis un an nous
devons en revanche incontestablement
faire davantage et accélérer leur
utilisation et à l'instar des téléphones
grave danger le gouvernement sans
achètera autant que nécessaire l'enjeu
réside désormais donc dans leur
déploiement et leur utilisation eric
dupond moretti a également oeuvré à
augmenter le nombre d'ordonnancés de
protection qui protège les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales
indépendamment des plaintes qu'elles
peuvent poser parce que vous savez que
certaines d'entre elles sont tellement
sous emprise elles ont tellement peur
elles ont tellement honte parfois
qu'elles n'osent pas déposé plainte et
bien avec ses ordonnances de protection
nous pouvons les protéger sans même
qu'elle n'ait a déposé plainte et les
résultats sont au rendez vous puisque
nous avons enregistré une augmentation
de 62 % des demandes au entre septembre
2018 et septembre 2020 72 juridiction en
par ailleurs mis en place des circuits
de traitement dédié aux violences
intrafamiliales au pénal comme aux
civils et on a vu là aussi la nécessité
d'avoir un traitement spécifique et
protecteur le nombre de condamnations
prononcées pour le sujet qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui était de 22 mille deux cent
vingt-huit en 2017 et il est passé en
2020 à 33
1784 c'est une progression de 50% que
nous ne pouvons que saluer et cette
tendance haussière devrait s'accentuer
en 2021
mieux protéger les victimes c'est aussi
faire
de la lutte contre les violences
conjugales la priorité numéro un des
forces de l'ordre et gérald darmanin a
décidé de renforcer le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes sur ce sujet
presque 90 mille policiers et gendarmes
ont ainsi reçu une formation pour un
meilleur accueil et un accompagnement
des victimes et en parallèle depuis le
grenelle des violences conjugales
123 travailleurs sociaux ont été
recrutés et on en recense aujourd'hui
394 au total pour sensibiliser les
forces de l'ordre à l'accueil et à la
prise en charge des femmes victimes de
violences enfin pour mieux suivre les
auteurs de violences le gouvernement a
décidé de renforcer le contrôle et la
death obtention et l'acquisition des
armes cela va se traduire par
l'élargissement du périmètre du fichier
national des personnes interdites
d'accès d'acquisition et de détention
d'armes
aux décisions pré et post
sentenciel ainsi que la mise en place
d'une interconnexion plus importante
entre ce fichier et les casiers
judiciaires
nous allons également créer un fichier
des personnes condamnées pour des
violences conjugales afin de faciliter
le partage d'informations entre les
forces de l'ordre et les services de la
justice ce fichier sera actualisé en
fonction des actions conduites par les
services de police et de gendarmerie et
des mesures prononcées par la justice il
favorisera ainsi la vision d'ensemble et
les détection des signaux faibles
permettant la prise de mesures
d'accompagnement de prévention et de
protection enfin le renforcement de la
coordination territoriale et notre
engagement au plus près des victimes
constitue une priorité absolue
je ne veux plus entendre des personnes
me dire madame la ministre je connais
une personne qui est victime de violence
mais je ne sais pas quoi faire et nous
en avons d'ailleurs déjà parlé madame la
présidente les terribles féminicide
hayange et de mérignac nous ont montré
qu'il y avait des dysfonctionnements
importants sur le terrain et un déficit
de coordination entre les acteurs à
chaque fois même si le dispositif de
protection étaient disponibles ils n'ont
pas forcément été mobilisés faute de
circulation de l'information entre les
différents services de suivi par ta ou
de suivi partagés sur les situations
individuelles
en somme la coordination est la clé de
la réussite de notre action collective
en matière de lutte contre les violences
parce qu'on le voit bien il suffit qu'il
y ait un seul maillon de la chaîne qui
ne joue pas son rôle pour que les
conséquences à l'arrivée soit totalement
dramatique la question du pilotage local
des politiques de lutte contre les
violences constitue dès lors un enjeu
crucial elle permet une réelle
effectivité et efficacité des
dispositifs de protection des victimes
et de suivi des auteurs de violences
conjugales c'est pourquoi le premier
ministre a décidé d'optimiser le partage
d'informations entre les acteurs locaux
afin d'améliorer leur coordination et
mieux protéger les victimes et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que j'étais très
heureuse d'être con des maires ruraux de
france parce qu on ne le dira jamais
assez dans les zones rurales les mères
sont souvent les premiers contacts des
victimes de violences conjugales ce
meilleur partage d'informations se
traduira dans la pratique par la mise en
place d'un comité de suivi des
situations individuelles piloté par la
justice et elle se réunira mensuellement
et à pilotage renforcé des mesures de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes avec une seule instance au niveau
départemental se réunira également tous
les trois mois pour discuter de ces
sujets donc nous aurons une partie
opérationnelle qui réunira tous les
acteurs locaux y compris les
associations tous les mois et au niveau
stratégique cette réunion aura lieu tous
les trois mois autour du préfet autour
du préfet n'est ce pas la circulaire
permettant cette coordination a été
publié au début du mois de septembre et
cette circulaire permettra de simplifier
le nombre d'instances de pilotage de la
politique de lutte contre les violences
où vous le savez il y as souvent au
niveau local beaucoup de silos dans les
différentes actions qui sont menées et
même lorsque les personnes sont de très
bonnes volontés et bien la coordination
et le travail collectif
n'est pas toujours aussi efficace que
nous le souhaiterions et cette
coordination est notre leitmotiv pour
que nos réponses soient le plus
efficaces possible sur le terrain
une coordination au niveau local mais
aussi et surtout au niveau local au
niveau national pardon mais surtout
aussi au niveau local pour réaliser ce
dernier kilomètre est donc absolument
indispensable pour lutter contre les
violences et en ligne de mire il s'agit
aussi de faire émerger les territoires
en difficulté d'identifier les besoins
réels et spécifiques de certaines
localités qui sont parfois éloigné de
certains dispositifs vous l'aurez
compris ce combat contre ce fléau des
violences intra familiales constitue une
véritable priorité de notre gouvernement
et j'organiserai le 14 octobre prochain
une grande journée de débat sur ces
sujets qui réunira non seulement les
associations les victimes les experts
mais aussi les élus parce que je crois à
la force des témoignages à la force du
partage des bonnes pratiques et plus
nous parlons de ces sujets plus la
société s'en empare au-delà de ces
mesures spécifiques pour lutter contre
les violences faites aux femmes le
gouvernement et la majorité ont adopté
des mesures fortes et extrêmement
concrètes pour favoriser l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes sans vous faire
de liste à la prévert je voudrais vous
en rappeler quelques unes l'allongement
du congé paternité qui est passé de 14 à
28 jours depuis le 1er juillet dernier
la mise en place du service public des
pensions alimentaires qui est en vigueur
depuis le 1er janvier pour en finir avec
les impayés qui plonge beaucoup de
familles monoparentales dans une grande
précarité et 85% de ces familles sont
portés par des femmes 2 engagement que
j'avais pris devant vous il y a un an et
que nous avons concrétisé depuis avec
olivier vérins et adrien taquet et je
pense également bien sûr à la gratuité
de la contraception pour toutes les
femmes jusqu'à 25 ans qui a été annoncé
par le ministre des solidarités de la
santé il y a quinze jours c'est
mesures importantes de solidarité et les
crédits il y dit que nous avons débloqué
pour lutter contre la précarité mensuel
qui touche aujourd'hui 2 millions de
femmes dans notre pays et s'il faut
évidemment se garder de verser dans le
l'autosatisfaction je crois que toutes
ces actions sont des mesures d'une très
grande ampleur qui oeuvrent à favoriser
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et à lutter contre la précarité et je
tiens à remercier la majorité
parlementaire de nous avoir soutenus
dans leur adoption et leur mise en
oeuvre permettez moi maintenant
d'aborder un autre enjeu qui est corrélé
à ce que je viens d'évoquer c'est
l'égalité professionnelle et
l'autonomisation économique des femmes
je sais madame la présidente combien
vous êtes sensible à ces questions nous
en avons discuté à plusieurs reprises et
lutter contre les inégalités salariales
est a été un sujet dont le gouvernement
s'est emparé de 2018 en créant l'index
de l'égalité professionnelle depuis 2000
20 mars 2020 il est obligatoire cet
index pour les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés et il a commencé à faire ses
preuves même si on se rend compte qu'il
ya encore beaucoup de progrès à faire le
taux de répondants s'est
considérablement améliorée puisqu'il est
passé à ce de 59 % en 2020 à 70 % au 1er
mars 2021 et si la note moyenne augmente
d'un point par rapport à 2020 pour
s'établir à 85 sur 100 et bien force est
de constater que seuls 2 % des
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés dans
notre pays arrivent à payer les femmes
et les hommes le même salaire alors même
que ça devrait être la norme
et 13 % de ces entreprises oublie encore
d'augmenter les femmes à leur retour de
congé maternité
bien que cette disposition soit prévue
dans la loi depuis 2006 c'est la preuve
qu'il reste des marges de progression et
que la majorité des entreprises doit
encore produire des efforts
significatifs pour faire progresser cet
index
par ailleurs à la fin du mois le sénat
examinera la proposition de loi portée
par marie-pierre x1 et christophe
castaner et que l'assemblée nationale a
voté à l'unanimité au mois de mai
dernier j'ai l'intimé conviction que ce
texte sera une véritable révolution pour
les femmes et pour notre société tout
entière et des pays au niveau
international s'intéresse déjà à ce que
nous avons fait et au delà des quotas
qu'elle instaurera je considère qu'en
s'attaquant au vivier des l'enseignement
supérieur et aux places en crèche pour
les mères seules il s'agit d'une loi qui
aura un impact profond sur l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans
notre société g dès lors toute confiance
dans les élus de cette haute assemblée
sous l'impulsion de votre délégation
pour rejoindre le chemin tracé vers
l'égalité par cette proposition de loi
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices toutes les mesures que je
viens d'évoquer devant vous s'appuie sur
un effort budgétaire important
je le sais l'argent c'est le nerf de la
guerre qu'on le veuille ou non et le
budget alloué à mon ministère a augmenté
de 40% en 2021 et ils augmentent pardon
en 2020 et il augmentera encore de 25%
je reprends il a augmenté de 40% en 2021
et il augmentera encore de 25% l'année
prochaine cette hausse budgétaire sans
précédent
traduit dans les faits que nous sommes
totalement engagés pour faire avancer
cette grande cause du quinquennat et
c'est 9,1 millions d'euros que nous
obtiendrons pour 2022 que nous avons
obtenus pour 2022 vont permettre de
travailler sur trois sujets importants
d'abord la prévention et la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes parce
que c'est encore un travail de longue
haleine ensuite l'égalité économique
entre les femmes et les hommes et enfin
l'accès au droit et la diffusion de la
culture de l'égalité les crédits du
programme 137 dévolu aux associations
seront ainsi soit stabilisée soit en
progression ces crédits supplémentaires
seront consacrés à la montée en
puissance des mesures issues notamment
du grenelle je pense par exemple à
l'extension du 39 19 au renforcement de
la structuration du réseau de lieux
d'écouté d'accompagnement et
d'orientation et des accueils de jour
ainsi que leur maillage territorial et
je pense aussi à la montée en charge des
centres de prise en charge des auteurs
de violences
et concernant l'exécution sur lequel
vous m'avez interrogé madame la
présidente le taux d'exécution des
crédits du programme 137 pour l'exercice
2001 s'élevait à
99,43 % je ne voulais laisser aucun
centime il s'agit là des autorisations
d'engagement et en termes de crédits de
paiement nous étions à
98,83 %
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices le combat pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes est porté
par l'ensemble de ce gouvernement ce
combat transcende les clivages partisans
ce combat n'est pas zen combat
idéologique c'est un combat culturel et
c'est un enjeu de civilisation
les progrès que nous avons accomplis
depuis quatre ans sont le résultat d'un
travail de co-construction que nous
devons absolument poursuivre je sais
évidemment le travail important réalisé
par le sénat et plus particulièrement
par votre délégation et le rôle à la
fois d'aiguillon et de vigie que vous
jouez c'est pourquoi je veux encore une
fois vous en remercier et que je sais
pouvoir compter sur votre engagement
sans faille comme vous savez que vous
pouvez compter sur le mien en retour je
vous remercie pour votre attention
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
ces propos qui ont l'avantagé de
répondre à beaucoup de questions qui
vous avait été posée dans mon propos
liminaires et donc je vais d'ores et
déjà immédiatement passé la parole au
sénateur au snack tris qu'ils ont
demandée pour vous interroger et donc je
vais passer la parole en premier un
martine filleul
même la ministre bien merci de votre
présentation tout h et détaillée et très
exhaustive j'aurais souhaité vous
interroger sur deux sujets le premier
que vous avez évoqué m'intéresse
beaucoup et je partage votre analyse à
propos des instances de pilotage et la
nécessaire coordination entre tous les
acteurs qui interviennent
localement autour des sujets de
violences faites aux femmes ça
m'apparaît vraiment une priorité et je
trouve que vraiment
c'est vraiment très bien de dix pensent
et de les mettre en place cependant je
voulais vous demander comment vous avez
prévu enfin qui avez vous prévu de
mettre autour de la table moi dans ma
région quelle que soit la bonne volonté
des uns et des autres je dispose de très
peu d'informations et j'ai beaucoup de
mal à obtenir l'information sur
la situation les chiffres les moyens mis
à disposition et je me posais la
question de savoir si vous aviez à
l'intention d'associer tout ou partie
des parlementaires et comment dans
quelles instances précisément
ensuite je voulais vous poser la
question une question financière
vous avez évoqué des nouveaux projets ou
l'approfondissement d'un certain nombre
de politiques déjà mises en place tout
ça est très bien mais nécessite je pense
des moyens des concentrés pour rendre
très efficace
l'opérationnalité et il s'avère qu'il y
avait des départements des régions qui
sont vraiment dépourvus de moyens ou qui
ont des moyens qui sont complètement
insuffisant par rapport à l'importance
des situations dans ma région des hautes
france par exemple c'est le cas on a
quelques personnes qui sont deux je
crois qu'ils sont vraiment
extraordinairement dévoués qui font un
travail formidable mais les moyens en
accompagnement enfin j'allais dire on au
secrétariat même chez les dames ne sont
pas exacts ils sont vraiment très
démunis et se repose beaucoup sur les
forces associatives est ce que vous avez
prévu des moyens supplémentaires
déconcentrer voilà c'était ma deuxième
question je vous remercie bon
merci chers collègues je laisse
peut-être madame la ministre réponde à
cette première série de questions qui et
qui alimenté par les territoires et
c'est vrai que chacun son ressenti il ya
des mesures et après il ya là le
ruissellement dans les départements qui
est important je vous laisse répondre
madame la ministre
mais commencer par la deuxième question
parce que c'est la plus simple d'un
point de vue financier je suis bien
consciente que tous les territoires ne
disposent pas des mêmes moyens
financiers et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que j'ai décidé de
d'investir si je puis dire la quasi
totalité de mon budget de l'augmentation
de budget que nous avons reçues aux
associations locales parce que quand je
vous parlais tout à l'heure des fameux
derniers kilomètres je suis bien
consciente que sans les associations
nous n'y arriverions pas par conséquent
nous avons un
un large maillage territorial en termes
d'associations et c'est assez fabuleux
de se rendre compte que bien qu'il y en
ai déjà beaucoup il y en a de plus en
plus qui se créent au quotidien et c'est
pour ça que nous allons les neuf dans
les 9 millions que nous avons obtenus en
plus eh bien je crois que presque 80 %
de ce budget va être investi pour aider
les associations qui travaillent sur les
les questions d des violences localement
je ne sais pas je ne sais d'un point de
vue je sais qu'il ya des budgets qui
sont octroyés par les régions par les
départements je sais que certains
départements sont sous dotées par
rapport à l'ampleur du
travail qui lie à faire c'est pour ça
que nous travaillons beaucoup avec les
collectivités locales et territoriales
pour les sensibiliser sur ces questions
c'est pour ça que dans la journée que
nous allons organiser au mois de fin la
semaine prochaine le 14 octobre eh bien
nous avons décidé d'inviter des élus
locaux vous me posiez la question qui va
être
impliqué dans tous et dans toutes ces
questions moi je veux que nous ouvrions
le plus largement possible parce que les
acteurs là la chaîne de solidarité pour
traiter les violences faites aux femmes
est absolument colossal colossal vous
avez la police vous avez la justice vous
avez les associations vous avez les
délégués aux droits des femmes vous avez
les élus locaux et si nous n'avons pas
une bonne coordination de cette équipe
finalement et si les gens ne se parlent
pas on n'y arrivera pas donc on n'a pas
forcément malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui la visibilité sur tous les
budgets qui sont utilisés par les
collectivités locales et territoriales
et c'est probablement un travail sur
lesquels peut être nous pourrions
avancer ensemble parce que avec les
connaissances qui sont les vôtres
peut-être que ça pourrait nous être
extrêmement utile et c'est peut-être un
chantier que nous devrions adressé en
termes de coordination
locale les personnes que nous avions
décidé de réunir autour du préfet comme
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
police-justice évidemment c'est les
délégués aux droits des femmes ce sont
les ars et ce sont les associations
parce que ce sont là les quatre ou cinq
acteurs que je viens de vous citer là
sont ceux qui ont la meilleure
connaissance de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
c'est vers ces personnes là que très
souvent les victimes se tourne
lorsqu'elles sont en difficulté messi
alors évidemment les élus sont impliqués
certains sont plus impliqués que
d'autres mais c'est quelque chose que
nous avons déjà discuté avec le
ministère de l'intérieur et puisque le
préfet va être celui qui va piloter ces
comités de pilotage je ne puis imaginer
qu'ils oublient les élus locaux dans ce
travail mais peut-être que ça mérite
d'être rappelé quand je vois vos yeux je
me dis que peut-être j'ai compris le
message j'ai compris le message et comme
je les dis il y a deux structures
différentes il ya une structure
opérationnelle
qui va davantage traiter des situations
individuelles
vous voyez et puis il y à là le comité
de pilotage stratégique qui lui sera
plus resserré
et ce que j'ai répondu à vos questions
je crois que notre collègue martine
filleul voulais juste rebondir sur je
voyais qu'elle me faisait signe alors je
lui redonne avec les yeux je lui redonne
la parole si présidente oui je crois
m'être mal exprimée par rapport à la
première partie de ma question
par rapport aux moyens vous m'avez
répondu sur les associations et je vous
en remercie beaucoup mais moi je voulais
parler des moyens des services
départementaux
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
certains départements n'ont pas de
délégué départemental et d'autres n'ont
pas de moyens nécessaires pour bien
fonctionner mr pardonnez-moi de non
seulement c'est peut-être moi qui ai mal
répondu à votre question parce que vous
avez parfaitement raison nous n'avons
pas toujours la visibilité sur ce qui se
passe dans certains départements dans
certaines régions encore moins sur les
budgets exact qui sont investis vous
savez combien chacun est un peu jaloux
de ce type d'information et c'est pour
ça qu'il serait peut-être
intéressant madame la présidente que
nous puissions travailler ensemble et
voir comment nous pouvons motiver
certains départements et certaines
régions à une meilleure collaboration
avec l'état pour pour pouvoir répondre à
cette question mais c'est un bon point
sur lequel aujourd'hui ça reste un peu
une nébuleuse je le reconnais merci
madame la ministre alors je fais prendre
peut-être deux questions par
une autre réponse peut être partout
oui
ah non je prend fin votre question
portait sur notre réseau
les délégués aux droits des femmes elles
seront dans les départements de
démissionner lmnp éventuellement j'étais
resté sur les moyens financiers des
régions et des départements
pardonnez-moi d'accord donc a priori
nous avons une lancée même pas a priori
je suis certaine que nous avons une
déléguée enfin un un délégué ça peut
être un ou une déléguée par département
ça c'est une certitude on a également
une équipe régionale de quatre personnes
qui est composée d'une directrice d'une
adjointe d'une chargé de mission et d'un
cadre de région de gestion pardon et
nous avons également les mêmes
structures sur les dom
ça je peux vous le garantir je n'ai pas
l'impression que vous soyez convaincus
de cela d'où vient votre doute aimé
écouter chevet et peut-être réactualisé
mes informations ou mais moi je n'ai pas
eu le sentiment qu'il y avait des
équipes aussi fourni dans dans
maraîchers bien et c'est ce qui devrait
être le cas alors je ne parle pas des
postes vacants mais en tout cas c'est ce
que nous avons construit dans les
régions et départements donc si vous
avez des exemples de de défaillance
n'hésitez pas à nous les remontées nous
allons regarder la raison pour laquelle
ça n'est pas le cas ils ce sont les
équipes constituées en tout cas ce sont
les ressources humaines que nous avons
dans ces départements et dans et dans
ces régions alors peut-être que juste
pour préciser on
département région dans chaque
département il doit y avoir donc dans ce
département il doit y avoir une déléguée
ça ça c'est jonathan et s'il ya un
département où nous n'avons pas de
délégués je serais heureuse de le savoir
ensuite dans les régions nous avons
quatre personnes
une directrice une aide d'une directrice
adjointe une chargée de mission et un
cadre de gestion
alors je pense que la difficulté réelle
c'est que
en réalité puis on est prêt mais on gère
et c'est vrai que le délégué
départemental ou départementaux et bien
en réalité son sont les seuls à faire le
travail au niveau du département et sont
les premiers acteurs héros ont du mal
finalement parce que souvent ils sont
lorsque je dis sont seuls à porter le
sujet pour tout le département et la
région c'est loin d'autant plus dans
certaines régions qui sont devenus des
régions taille xxl et donc je crois que
l'efficacité
l'efficacité ça serait quand même
d'avoir des équipes dans chaque
département qui soit au plus près et qui
viennent étoffer le délégué qui n'a pas
incapacité à une sorte et voilà c'est
plus je vois le message qu'ils étaient
transmis je pense en marre parce que
autant vous vous avez répondu très
précisément sur finalement département
région on peut pas assimiler l'action de
la même manière au niveau de la région
au niveau des départements et tout se
passe au niveau du département et
lorsqu'on va mettre les personnes autour
de la table chaque mois que vous disiez
tout à l'heure eh bien ce sera la
déléguée de la région sera pas là enfoui
et donc sûrs à moi une perte
d'efficacité voilà c'est c'est plus
cette remarque voilà madame la ministre
c'est une
jeu est là et pour être très sincère
avec vous j'ai déjà entendu ces
remontées lorsque je suis un déplacement
sur le terrain et c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui me préoccupe beaucoup
parce que le sujet des violences est
maintenant sur la table donc la parole
se libère de plus en plus si nous
n'avons pas les bonnes personnes pour
pouvoir les recevoir les accueillir ça
ne fonctionnera pas donc
moi je suis bien consciente que notre
réseau pourrait être mieux étoffer c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire il pourrait
être mieux étoffer parce que les enjeux
et les besoins ont augmenté et je sais
que nous avons encore un travail en
profondeur à faire là dessus pour que
pour qu' elle soit mieux épauler et
mieux accompagner c'est quelque chose
sur quoi nous travaillons mais comme
vous le savez ça prend du temps parce
que ça prend du temps
pour illustrer madame la ministre est
vrai que lorsqu'on parle de la l'échelle
de la région en réalité nous qui sommes
sénateurs est en contact avec les maires
très régulièrement on s'aperçoit que
finalement eux mêmes ont un déficit de
d'interlocuteurs et par rapport à cela
donc bien entendu camair qui rencontrent
des problématiques il va bas à faire
appel à la région à l'équipe
la plus performante qu'elle soit sera
pas la région ça va être dans le
département qui va rechercher un soutien
une équipe et là je pense qu'on il faut
qu'on travaille à l'échelle du
département qui est déjà une grande
échelle et des grandes disparités d'un
bout à l'autre des départements mais
c'est cette remarque vous l'avez entendu
puisque après les masques on sait que
l'expression était plus compliqué on
n'avait pas compris forcément le sens de
la question mais à notre collègue
martine filleul ça n'en est pas moins
une très bonne question et et
je ne vous avais bien que l'augmentation
budgétaire et était significative je
sais bien qu'il faut aller plus le temps
passe et je sais qu'il faut aller plus
loin et il faut pas négliger l'impact
financier de ces affaires et puis le le
plafond d'emplois qui est très très très
très stricte traître c'est une bataille
chaque dp est une bataille
incommensurable comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer pour toutes les
administrations mais mais j'ai la
volonté de porter ces batailles là parce
qu elles en valent la peine donc merci
madame la sénatrice merci madame la
ministre alors du coup on va passer la
parole aux deux sénatrices qui suivent
dominique j'ai rien et laurence cohen on
va prendre vos deux qui suit en même
temps et ensuite on prendra les deux
autres sénateurs centristes qui ont
demandé la parole
alors tu n'avais rien et ensuite grand
poème
merci beaucoup à la présidente remercie
un ami nice pour pour toutes ces
présentations
je me permet de
relier encore un petit peu plus ce que
ma collègue martine filleul vous a dit
sur les réunions autour du préfet le
préfet ne fera pas si on lui demande pas
de mettre les parlementaires autour de
la table donc c'est mieux si c'est prévu
dès l'origine
éventuellement pas forcément sur la
partie opérationnelle au moins sur la
partie stratégie peut-être enfin voilà
en tout cas je sais que ça peut arriver
puisque moi j'ai cette chance comme nous
travaillons sur le sujet au niveau de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et
qu'il y à des réunions régulières et que
je travaille avec une bonne partie des
acteurs qui se trouvaient autour de la
table j'ai pu y être associés mais
c'était de façon
non conventionnelle dirons nous donc
c'est mieux si les choses se sont
précisées donc je me permets d'insister
sur les délégués aux droits des femmes
il vaudrait mieux en avoir deux dans
chaque département et personne à la
région parce que je je dis je confirme
ce que disait notre présidente sur les
aides aux associations merci beaucoup
parce que
dans un département rural le cidff par
exemple a les moyens d'être en ville n'a
pas les moyens d'être à la campagne il
lui faut des relais mais et s'il n'a pas
de moyens et déjà même en étant en ville
c'est très compliqué d'avoir une juriste
à temps plein alors que parce qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup d'habitants donc on n'a pas
beaucoup de ressources alors qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup de cas donc c'est pas
toujours proportionnelle donc merci de
les regarder de près je vais passer à
d'autres sujets
la formation puisque si l'on parle
d'égalité fille garçon et d'égalité
hommes femmes dans le milieu
professionnel
il faut la préparer en amont et
quel travail
avez vous souhaitez vous engager temps
avec monsieur blanc caire que madame
vidal pour essayer de faire en sorte que
les filières
masculine se féminiser féminine se
masculinise parce que je pense que c'est
dans les deux sens qu'il faut le voir
pour avoir une meilleure répartition je
ne pense pas plus juste qu'il n'y ait
pas une seule femme ingénieur que le
fait que bientôt on aura plus d'hommes
magistrat je pense que c'était une vraie
réflexion mais qu'elle est comme on le
fait tout et puis je pense que ça peut
être bien puisqu'on voit bien qu'une
une profession qui se féminise c'est une
plaie une profession qui se paupérise
étonnamment les salaires baissent et
ensuite un autre point que vous n'avez
pas abordé qui est une question que dont
nous avons débattu plusieurs fois nos
niveaux de la délégation aux droits des
femmes qui est la prostitution
dans toutes ses variantes que ce soit la
prostitution étudiante dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment mais évidemment la
prostitution des femmes
immigrées qui peuvent être en gros et
esclavagisés clairement donc est ce
qu'il y à des démarches de fait sur le
sujet voilà merci donc laurence cohen
qui a demandé la parole et après je vous
laisserai répondre je vais merci merci
beaucoup madame la ministre pour vos
propos introductif qui était
effectivement très complet qui sut qui
décrivait un peu tous tous les domaines
puisque effectivement l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et 1 était un
sujet transversal
moi je voudrais vous vous interrogez
plus spécialement finalement sur trois
dans trois domaines le premier domaine
c'est que nous avons vu avec la la
pandémie le rôle très important
des femmes dans un certain nombre de mis
de métier je pense notamment à tous les
métiers dans le secteur des soins et des
liens et on a vu combien elle était en
première ligne en terme de souffrance de
non reconnaissance parce que
effectivement c'est considéré comme une
comète et des professions ayant des
formations mineurs un jeu et donc pas
besoin de formation qui dit pas besoin
de formations spécifiques mendy petit
salaire et petits salaires
effectivement ça ça se répercute sur
tout le parcours y compris au niveau des
retraites y compris également sur des
temps de travail morcelé sont les femmes
quand même qui ont le plus de temps
partiel qui sont imposés et donc là
encore il y à il y a des conséquences
donc j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
travaillé j'en suis persuadé mais enfin
quelles sont vos conclusions les pistes
que vous ouvrez pour
essayer vraiment de résoudre ce problème
parce que à chaque fois que je me pose
cette question aux différents ministres
du travail sont toujours assez content
où elles sont toujours assez contente
des mesures mais on est en 2021 et ça ne
bouge pas beaucoup donc je pense qu'il
ya besoin vraiment de mettre toutes et
tous les acteurs et tous les actrices
autour de la table pour essayer de
d'avancé sur ce problème ma deuxième
question c'est au tour toujours de
l'égalité professionnelle et là c'est
autour d'une mesure qui a été porté par
par le gouvernement actuel sur l'index
sur l'égalité professionnelle et en 2020
il ya 96 % des entreprises de plus de
1000 salariés qui ont obtenu 75 sur 100
à l'index et n'ont donc pas eu
d'obligation à corriger les inégalités
pourtant comme on a pu le souligner est
bien les écarts de salaires sont
toujours aussi élevés
puisque c'est je crois 26% en moyenne et
ça c'est suivant l'insee l'adar l'adar s
donc il ya eu beaucoup de demandes au
niveau des syndicats
réunis d'ailleurs en mettant en cause le
manque de transparence et une surtout
une auto évaluation des employeurs que
personne ne peut vérifier donc est ce
que là vous avez effectivement
des pistes ouvert des pistes de travail
pour modifier cet état de fait troisième
élément c'est toujours au niveau du
travail c'est sur les violences qui sont
subis et on s'aperçoit que les femmes
qui sont victimes de violence au travail
et bien malheureusement pour la majorité
d'entre elles
elles elles perdent leur emploi soit
parce que elle démissionne quand le vol
avec le harceleur qui en général n'est
pas sanctionné soit carrément elles sont
licenciées donc là encore
j'aimerais avoir votre votre analyse là
dessus et les pistes que vous pouvez
réouvre ouvrir et ma toute dernière
question va dans le sens de celles que
dominique vienne poser c'est par rapport
à la la prostitution au niveau du sénat
tous partis politiques confondus nous
avons été plusieurs à mener la bataille
pour que cette loi 2
soit soit adoptée ça a été compliqué et
maintenant c'est son application c'est à
dire qu'il y a très peu de personnes qui
sont
prostituées qui voudrait sortir de cette
prostitution qui arrive à être réinsérés
et on avait vu dans les différents
budgets que malheureusement la part mise
en termes de moyens étaient très faibles
donc est ce que là vous avez pu avancer
pour déployer des moyens supplémentaires
et dans le même ordre d'idée j'en suis
désolé parce que je suis déjà trop
longue mais nous sommes très attentive à
la prostitution des mineurs est très
inquiète et inquiet parce que on voit se
développer malheureusement cette
prostitution vraiment dans tous les
territoires
que ce soit en zone urbanisée ou en zone
rurale avec
finalement bad et des professionnels
pour qu'ils sont démunis que ce soit au
niveau des enseignants ou au niveau des
travailleurs sociaux face à cette
prostitution mois dans le département du
val de marne malgré le soutien de la
procureure et cetera c'est quand même
très compliqué donc là aussi est-ce que
vous avez des pistes
merci davance
merci mesdames les sénatrices il est
juste une remarque je voudrais faire
avant de commencer à vous répondre
madame la sénatrice est rien vos
remarques celle de madame fille elle est
la vôtre me font penser qu' il faut que
nous fassions un courrier spécifique aux
préfets pour leur rappeler qu'il est
extrêmement important d'inviter les élus
locaux à ces rencontres
mensuel t
je mon équipe va prendre ça parce que
nous ne sommes pas des îles locale
si vous dites élus locaux nous oublier
nous donner le nom je sais bien que vous
n'êtes pas je parlais pas de vous parce
que je ne parlais pas de vous je sais
bien que vous n'êtes pas des noms je
pensais parce que pour nous c'est une
évidence parce que nous travaillons déjà
avec certains maires mais il me semble
important de rappeler au préfet de ne
pas oublié de convier les élus locaux je
ne sais pas si à votre niveau ce genre
de rencontres est intéressante aussi
d'accord donc nous nous d'accès c'est ce
qui nous permet de savoir ce qui se
passe sur le terrain justement puisque
comme vous le savez nous n'avons plus le
droit d'être mère donc ne pourront pas
assister en tant qu'élu local manière
pour vous et décors très bien donc nous
allons prendre ce sujet et voir comment
nous assurer qu'il y ait que compte que
l'on n'oublie personne en tout cas aucun
des acteurs importants sur cette
question vous m'avez interrogé madame la
sénatrice sur la culture l égalité et la
manière dont on peut lutter contre les
stéréotypes finalement parce que je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous sur le
fait que c'est dès le plus jeune âge que
l'on doit pouvoir se saisir de ces
questions et ça commence évidemment à
l'école je dirais même à la maison ce
n'est même la maison ensuite l'école que
ce soit l'école maternelle primaire et
ensuite tout au long de la vie et je
crois que l'une des premières choses
qu'il faut que nous commencions par
faire c'est déconstruire les stéréotypes
que ce soit les petites filles que ce
soit des petits garçons le sujet que
nous avons c'est que les parents eux
mêmes sont toujours très stéréotypé et
les préjugés sont là donc on a mené avec
jean michel blanquer un travail
important pour faire en sorte que les
enseignants soient déjà eux-mêmes formés
on est passé je crois de quatre heures à
18 heures de formation sur les questions
de la culture à l'égalité parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux
n'avaient jamais eu de travail fait sur
ce sujet là et on a prévu une prise en
charge d'un module de formation dans la
formation initiale mais aussi dans la
formation continue de l'égalité sur
l'égalité obligatoire pour les
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
l'année dernière par exemple vingt mille
enseignants ont pu ainsi être formés à
cette culture à l'égalité et on a
également des conseils de vie au collège
qui
quiconque il ya le conseil de vie au
collège et le conseil de vie au lycée
qui est dédié finalement dont la
responsabilité est de faire un
diagnostic
de
du travail annuel qui a été fait sur
l'égalité parce que bien que le ministre
donne les directives après chaque chef
d'établissement va appliquer et mettre
en oeuvre ce qu'il souhaite donc ce
conseil de vie collégiens et lycéens
permet justement d'aller plus loin et de
s'assurer que ce ne soit pas oublié et
je peux vous dire des déplacements que
j'ai fait dans les collèges fait souvent
dans les collèges les lycées les
universités et je peux vous dire qu'il
ya une telle volonté des jeunes filles
aujourd'hui de se saisir de ces
questions que je sens que les choses
sont véritablement engagée et puis on a
aussi travaillé avec
laissés nus pour que l'égalité soit
également dans les sites éducative pour
qu'elle soit introduite en termes de
thématiques sur tous les sujets
transversaux qui sont adressées donc
voilà les différents sujets que nous
avons travaillé avec avec jean michel
blanquer et en ce qui concerne frédéric
vidal l'enseignement supérieur
si vous avez commencé à voir la
proposition de loi de marie pierre x1 on
a justement des dispositions dans ses
propositions de loi pour augmenter
le nombre de jeunes filles qui vont dans
certains secteurs qui sont considérées
comme complètement gérer ce genre aient
par le ton je pense aux sciences et aux
technologies aux mathématiques et
l'ingénierie ou les entreprises
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont par exemple dans
les secteurs de l'aéronautique ou du
bâtiment me disent mais madame la
ministre nous on veut bien embaucher des
femmes mais on n'a pas de viviez et si
on ne prépare pas ce vivier des
l'enseignement supérieur ce problème va
se perpétuer sans fin vous voudrez finir
sur un sujet qui me tient extrêmement à
coeur c'est les role models
si on voit beaucoup de femmes sénatrice
et bien d'autres jeunes filles se diront
que elles aussi peuvent devenir
sénatrice si on voit de plus en plus de
femmes qui vont dans l'espace et bien
que se diront que c'est possible pour
elle et je trouve que
l'un des défis que nous avons nous les
femmes qui avons réussi à percer ce
fameux plafond de verre c'est de parler
raconter expliquer à l'est que ce soit
dans les médias que ce soit dans la
presse que ce soit dans les écoles que
partout où nous pouvons partager nos
histoires et montrer que c'est possible
il faut que nous le fassions et il n'y a
pas de meilleure loi que les témoignages
vivants et c'est pour cela que nous
avons beaucoup travaillé avec rosie mme
bachelot sur la représentation des
femmes dans les médias sané enfin voir
des femmes infirmières des femmes
maîtresses d'école c'est bien mais il ya
aussi des femmes astronautes il ya des
femmes astrophysicienne il ya des femmes
dans tous les métiers dans le bâtiment
dans l'automobile et on ne les voit pas
suffisamment est donc cette
représentation est également aussi
importante pour déconstruire les
stéréotypes
vous m'avez madame la sénatrice
également interrogé sur la question de
la prostitution et c'est une question
qui est évidemment extrêmement
importante non seulement pour nos jeunes
filles parce que la prostitution est de
plus en plus important des de plus en
plus jeunes mais également sur les
questions des femmes migrantes et ces
questions et me permets de rappeler
d'abord que la france est l'un des rares
pays avec la suède à avoir totalement
assumé sa position abolitionniste et
on a enfin vous avez voté en 2016 cette
loi pour protéger les victimes du
système prostitutionnel et le
gouvernement a décidé qu'il y aurait
dans chaque département une commission
départementale
dont l'objectif est de lutter contre la
prostitution et nous avons constaté
l'année dernière que ça n'était enfin
tous les départements n'étaient pas très
avancées sur ces questions c'est un
euphémisme
et si et là encore si la loi dit une
chose et que l'application sur le
terrain n'est pas à la hauteur nous n'y
arriverons jamais c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire donc dans ce cadre on a
décidé de soutenir de manière de manière
beaucoup plus volontariste déjà les
associations qui au niveau
national ou local travaille sur des
conventions pluriannuelles et on a
déployé
595 1000 euros en 2021 qui sont allés à
des structures comme la lc comme
l'amicale du nid comme le
le mouvement du nid où le ce cce m on a
également décidé de financer la location
financière d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle la fille ce que vous
connaissez à hauteur de 1 million cent
quarante mille euros et vous le savez
elle s'adresse en particulier aux femmes
migrantes et au niveau local on a
déployé plus de 2 millions d'euros pour
là encore soutenir les associations qui
travaillent directement sur le terrain
avec les les femmes en situation de
prostitution j'ai fait des maraudes je
me rends compte combien c'est compliqué
c'est un sujet extrêmement complexe et
l'état seul ne peut pas gérer mais les
associations sur le terrain font un
travail remarquable donc si les
associations font leur travail et que
derrière cela nous avons des préfets
dans les départements ces commissions
l'objectif étant que dans chaque
département d'ici la fin de cette année
si je ne m'abuse nous ayons une
commission et que cette commission se
réunisse parce que parfois elles
existaient mais elles ne se réunissait
pas c'est un travail titanesque et un
comité national de suivi parce qu'on a
bien vu que ça ne fonctionnait pas si
bien que ça sur le terrain on a mis
enfin on a eu réuni un comité national
le 15 février
ils 21 qui comprenait toutes les
directions d'administration centrale
concernée par la loi et les associations
spécialisées il ya eu une circulaire
interministérielle
qui est actuellement en train d'être
travaillé avec le ministère de
l'intérieur pour harmoniser les la mise
en oeuvre de la loi de 2016 sur le
terrain et à cela adrien taquet et moi
nous nous avons il y avait la conférence
des familles cette semaine et c'est un
sujet qui a encore revenue sur la table
et on a décidé d'avoir un plan très
ambitieux pour protéger les mineurs qui
s'adonnent à la prostitution
mais nous sommes bien conscients que
nous pouvons mieux faire sur cette
question là et nous allons continuer de
travailler dessus évidemment
[Musique]
madame la sénatrice cohen en ce qui
concerne la question vous m'avez posé
sur le sujet économique moi je c'est un
sujet qui me tient extrêmement à coeur
parce que comme gisèle halimi je crois
que l'émancipation des femmes passent
par leur autonomisation économique
et financière et déjà quand même
certaines choses qui ont été faites et
qui fonctionne l'index est l'une de ces
choses là on va y revenir parce que vous
m'avez posé mais quand même
reconnaissons que l'index il faut pas
oublier qu'il a été mis en place en 2018
et que
2019 et 2020 ont été une année
particulière et malgré ça les
entreprises ont commencé à s'en saisir
est ce que les résultats sont parfaits
non mais je sens bien qu'il y à une
progression je sens à chaque fois que je
parle de l'index que les entreprises
frémissent un peu donc l ont bien
compris que c'est au delà du fait que ce
soit obligatoire il y a le regard de
leurs employés sur la manière dont ces
index sont utilisés ou pas et puis
il y a également la ppl rixin qui est en
cours qui va renforcer cet aspect
économique et professionnelle pour les
femmes mais j'avoue que je partage
évidemment votre diagnostic et
particulièrement en ce qui concerne la
situation des femmes suite à la crise
sanitaire dont nous ne sommes pas encore
sortis les femmes ont été en première
ligne de cette crise et particulièrement
parce qu'elles occupent ces métiers qui
ont été absolument essentiel et
indispensable
je pense notamment au fait qu'il ya plus
de 85 % de femmes dans les métiers de la
santé qu'il ya plus de 85 % de femmes
dans les métiers des ehpad elles sont
dans l'édification elles sont dans la
propreté elles sont voilà elles sont
dans la distribution etc à tout ce titre
d'ailleurs que moi j'étais extrêmement
heureuse de voir l'effort considérable
qui a été fait par olivier ferrand pour
augmenter le salaire des dents le ségur
augmenter le salaire des métiers dans la
santé on a je crois que c'est pas loin
de 200 euros un parent promettent qu'ils
ont et par mois qu'ils ont été
octroyées aux professionnels de la santé
qui ont surtout bénéficié aux
infirmières et aux aides soignantes on a
également justement parce que la crise a
jeté une lumière très crue sur les
inégalités salariales en fait les
métiers occupés par les femmes sont les
minimes - payer les moins reconnus et
les moins valorisés et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela qu elisabeth bornes et en sort
en ce moment en train de travailler avec
les partenaires sociaux pour revaloriser
d'un point de vue financier les
travailleurs de la seconde ligne et
évidemment il faut que nous ayons une
mobilisation des partenaires sociaux
parce que
là encore une fois seul on n'y arrivera
pas c'est quand même un peu dommage
qu'on ait attendu la crise sanitaire
pour se rendre compte que les métiers
essentiels étaient les métiers porté par
les femmes vous avez également madame
cohen mentionné la question
sur l'index d'égalité professionnelle et
je vois votre doute quant à son bon
fonctionnement
mais au moins nous avons un outil
jusqu'à 2018 nous n'avions pas d'outils
pour pouvoir piloter cette égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
étendu l'obligation de transparence de
par les entreprises et d'avoir d'où les
sous-indicateurs qu'ils soient publiés
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'arbre qui cache
la forêt qu'on n'ait pas une très très
bonne note parce qu'on est très très bon
par exemple sur l'augmentation de
salaire des femmes et que on oublie tous
les autres index comme le fait de ne pas
augmenter les femmes qui rentre de congé
maternité maintenant il faut reconnaître
que c'est un index qui est récent que
tout le monde doit s'en emparer que
pendant la crise sanitaire ça a été
extrêmement difficile et évidemment nous
attaquer aux entreprises qui ne sont pas
arrivés à la note moyenne de 85 et je
crois que dans un souci de stabilisation
il était important de le laisser vivre
surtout dans une période aussi complexe
que que celle que nous avons traversée
et est ce qu'il faut le faire évoluer
personnellement je pense que oui est-ce
que c'était le bon moment de le faire
l'année dernière certainement pas parce
que je ne voulais pas qu'il y ait de
levée de boucliers et j'avais déjà
d'ailleurs entendu les entreprises nous
dire est ce qu'on peut ne pas travailler
sur l'index cette année déjà on n'a pas
cédé parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
continuité d'exécution mais au bout de
trois ans en 2018 2019 2020 pour les
entreprises de 50 salariés c'est
seulement l'année dernière qu'elles ont
commencé à publier donc où est ce qu'il
faut l'améliorer ce qu'il faut
progresser oui est ce qu'il faut le
suivre et le contrôle et oui est ce
qu'il faudra le faire évoluer dans le
temps très certainement mais pour
l'instant je crois qu'il est important
de le stabiliser
merci madame la ministre donc je vais
oui je pense que toro est en suspens oui
pardon excusez moi c'est oublié sur la
question des violences au travail alors
ça
ça aussi c'est une question extrêmement
importante parce que bon vous le savez
moi j'ai passé 30 ans dans le monde
professionnel est souvent j'ai constaté
que les personnes qui harcelait étaient
les personnes qui avaient le plus de
pouvoir dans l'entreprise et quand vous
tenez à votre travail c'est extrêmement
difficile d'aller dénoncer c'est ça la
vérité on n'a pas envie de perdre son
travail on n'a pas envie d'être
stigmatisés on n'a pas envie d'être
celui qu'on pointe du doigt comme le
fauteur de trouble ou souvent la
fauteuse de troubles et c'est pour ça
que c'est un volet essentiel de lutte
contre les violences on a pris dans la
loi de 2018 la loi du 5 septembre 2018
des mesures fortes par rapport à ça
d'abord les entreprises ont l'obligation
maintenant d'avoir des référents
violences en leur sein ce qui n'était
pas le cas
jusque là il ya également une obligation
d'information des salariés et il y a
aussi des guides spécifiques qui ont été
produits pour que les salariés puissent
parler mais certains salariés ne veulent
pas parler au sein de l'entreprise il
préfère le faire à l'extérieur de
l'entreprise et c'est pour ça que nous
soutenons une
association qui s'appelle
fnaca c'est ça l'association qui
l'association qui accompagne oui
non pas seulement le laboratoire de
l'égalité il ya une association qui
lutte spécifiquement sur la vrt merci
beaucoup qui luttent spécifiquement
contre les violences
qui arrive au sein du monde du travail
et que nous avons avec laquelle nous
avons renoué parce que les liens
s'étaient distendus
j'ai eu de longues discussions avec
marilyn et nous avons recommencé à
travailler un peu plus de manière un peu
plus forte elle et c'est une c voilà ce
sont des personnes extrêmement mobilisés
qui ont un réseau d'avocats et de
juristes incroyable et donc nous
travaillons avec elle pour faire en
sorte que quand les personnes n'ont pas
ni la force ni le courage ni l'envié de
parler au sein de l'entreprise elle
puisse s'appuyer sur sur ces
associations et c'est un sujet que nous
avons également traité évidemment dans
le cas du grenelle et je peux vous dire
j'ai il y a encore quelques semaines
j'étais en échange avec cinq entreprises
de la plus grande aux plus petites qui
ont décidé de s'impliquer
personnellement sur ces questions et
donc d'aller plus loin que les mesures
que nous avons prises certaines ont
offert des places d'hébergement
pour accueillir les fans qui étaient
victimes de violences il y a les espaces
de paroles qui ont été mises en oeuvre
il ya ces référents dont je parlais tout
à l'heure et
les entreprises bien qu'elle se saisisse
de ces questions nous dise quand même
c'est pas notre rôle on veut pas
s'immiscer dans la vie privée
et de nos salariés oui sauf que
certaines reconnaissent aussi qu'elles
ont des agresseurs parmi elles et que
donc si elle ne s'en saisissent pas
c'est aussi l'image de l'entreprise qui
peut être impacté donc il a aussi il y à
un véritable changement de mentalité et
je pense que nous sommes dans le bon
chemin mais encore une fois il faut être
on voudrait que ça aille plus vite mais
on est on est on est quand même bien en
tout cas la prise de conscience est là
et on avance progressivement et pour
terminer parce que moi aussi je suis
très longue du coup sur la prostitution
des mineurs vous le savez certainement
adrien attaqué a lancé en 2020 un groupe
de travail interministériel qui
regroupait à la fois des experts et des
associations et suite au rapport qui est
qui a découlé de ce groupe de travail eh
bien il va y avoir un plan très
ambitieux qui va être annoncé dans
quelques temps le phénomène
prostitutionnel est devenu de plus en
plus insidieux parce que avant on
pouvait le détecter quand les jeunes
filles allaient dans les hôtels au moins
on se rendait compte que peut-être il y
avait un problème d'âge et cetera
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux avec
les réseaux airbnb et cetera tout peut
se faire de manière extrêmement cacher
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a financé une
étude justement pour mieux analyser
cette cette prostitution qui est de plus
en plus jeunes et qui passe par les par
internet et c'est aussi pour ça que nous
finançons l'amicale du nid par exemple
qui va vers ces jeunes et qui a des
discussions avec eux pour faire de la
prévention et voilà la manière pour
l'instant dont nous saisissons de ces
questions
je vais alors cégeps et c'est adrien
taquet qui le portent donc je n'ai pas
mais on peut revenir vers vous là dessus
ouais on va revenir vers vous on va
prendre ce point et revenir vers vous
avec la réponse
merci beaucoup alors je fais passer la
parole aux trois sénateurs c'est la
triste qu'ils ont demandé dans l'ordre
jean michel arnaud patricia des masses
et u7
bourguiba la présidente merci madame le
ministre je serai très bref puisque leur
avance je vous remercie d'avoir d'autres
exposé complet je souhaiterais à venir
revenir sur wii
c'est très important souvent les femmes
qui sont victimes de violence sont très
très très dans une grande précarité
financière et je voulais juste rappeler
que on a mis en place le déblocage de
l'epargne salariale est
aujourd'hui ses 460 mille euros qui ont
été débloquées pour aider les femmes qui
lorsqu'elles quittent le foyer et qui
sont démunis financièrement et bien
c'est à nous les veys l'élément qui
permet de débloquer d'epargne salariale
pour leur permettre de se relancer dans
la vie voilà je vous le dis parce que
c'est quelque chose parfois qu'on oublie
et puisque vous êtes un relais important
aussi je voulais juste le préciser je
vous prie de m'excuser monsieur le
sénateur je vous rends la parole je vous
en prie vous êtes ici chez vous
je souhaitais poser de questions
précises la première sur un des points
que vous avez signalé parmi parmi
d'autres d'avancer dans l'action
gouvernementale le service fille de
paiement des pensions alimentaires
avez vous à ce jour des éléments
d'évaluation de l'effectivité
de la mise en oeuvre de services fixes
de paiement j'ai faut le comprendre que
sur le terrain les choses n'étaient pas
aussi
concrètes
qu'elles ne sont affichés aujourd'hui
deuxième sujet pour revenir à
l'intervention des deux collègues au
tout début de l'audition
oui on nous avons besoin d'une
participation active à la fois des
parlementaires et aussi des élus locaux
aux comités de coordination locale et je
vous invite comme cela se fait très
régulièrement dans les commissions de
consultation les commissions de travail
dans le cadre départemental à saisir le
réseau des associations départementales
de maires pour que pour la partie élu
local il puisse vous être fait des
propositions et généralement les
présidents de ces associations
départementales connaissent suffisamment
bien le terrain pour faire en sorte que
non seulement ces commissions puissent
être mises en oeuvre et qu'elle puisse
vivre et qu'on puisse avoir
effectivement des élus particulièrement
férus sur ces questions qui y
participent troisième observation ce
sera la dernière
je me permets de vous faire part de
mon étonnement quand je vois les
chiffres nous vérifierons notamment à la
commission des finances et puis avec les
commissions concernées sous sous le
regard
particulièrement attentive de la
délégation des augmentations de budget
importante puisque 40% vais vous
annoncer plus 25% pour 2022 40% en 2020
heures 25 % en 2022 parce que quand on
discute et qu'on interroge les acteurs
du terrain on se demande où vont ces
augmentations puisque cela a été dit
tout à l'heure de manière assez forte
les moyens ne sont pas forcément
toujours déployés même à loos a fortiori
avec un peu plus de chair beaucoup plus
compte de manière beaucoup plus
compliqué est de surcroît lorsque les
moyens sont développées notamment dans
les territoires ruraux cela se fait
essentiellement sur la concentration des
deux ou trois villes importantes du
département avec vraiment un no man's
land complet en matière d'intervention
puisque le réseau associatif ne se
déplace pas pour les mêmes raisons
financières dans les zones de ruralité
profonde et donc on a vraiment une
gestion à double à triple étage
particulièrement préjudiciable pour les
femmes rurales ont qu'on l'a évoqué dans
nos travaux dans le rapport de l'année
sur femmes et ruralité hausser nos
délégations que ça a été le fil
directeur de nos travaux durant toute
l'année et sur ce point particulier sur
finalement la solitude un certain nombre
de femmes dans les zones rurales voulait
également savoir si vous aviez des
éléments d'évaluation sur les offres
finalement que déplacement et de
logement d'urgence pour les hommes
violents afin que les fans nous avons
les agricultrices victimes de ces
violences puissent rester dans leur
ferme
merci patricia des masses
merci madame
merci madame la ministre effectivement
grand nombre de questions ont déjà été
posées je rejoins la question de mon
collègue sur la situation des femmes en
milieu rural et l'isolément aussi des
élus et vous l'avez justement 10 pour
les mers sont les premiers aiguilleurs
entre guillemets de la détresse mais
aussi les médecins les médecins de
famille
lorsqu'il lorsque les territoires ont la
chance d'en avoir aujourd'hui se pose
effectivement l'isolément de ces femmes
mais aussi d'isolement des élus en
matière d'information et de formation
parce que en situation d'urgence
l'urgence est de ne pas perdre de temps
et d'urgence et d'apporter des réponses
alors quelles sont elles comment cela
peut se traduire en milieu rural ça
c'est ma première question la seconde
serait celle de la formation et à la
fois des élus pour ne pas perdre dans
cette ibilité des procédures et dans la
complexité qu'elle re
est longue et aussi la formation de ces
femmes en milieu rural puisque l'
isolement et les situations sont souvent
génératrices de dépendances quelle
formation peut être distillées sur le
terrain qu'elles aident aussi pour ne
pas salir pour sortir de ce cercle a
sont autant de pistes de travail
effectivement sur lesquels je serai te
reo si vous interrogez pour avoir cette
visibilité de terrain puisque
malheureusement le maillage du
territoire en milieu rural est vraiment
là le talon d'achille de des élus et des
femmes malheureusement qui souffre de
cette situation
malheureusement on constate des zones
blanches dans le monde rural où il n'ya
pas d'acteurs identifié implantées sur
le territoire lorsque des violences
surviennent lorsque des femmes sont
victimes de violences ce que des femmes
avec des enfants sont victimes de
violence
s'offrait l'alternative suivante vous
quittez votre territoire pour aller dans
la structure susceptible de vous
accueillir et de vous héberger et elle
est souvent éloignée à trois quarts
d'heure une heure une heure et demie de
route et
beaucoup de femmes finissent par
renoncer à cette proposition pour ne pas
éloigner les enfants du lieu de
scolarisation et pour ne pas s'éloigner
elle même du lieu où elle travaille
des élus locaux des élus très engagé
très impliqué sur ce sujet ont imaginé
des solutions dont nous avons parlé qui
consistait parfois à réaffecter les
logements de fonction qui existait dans
les établissements scolaires ce qu'on
appelait les logements de fonction mis à
disposition des enseignants les
directeurs d'école pour les mettre à
disposition des femmes éventuellement
victimes de violence est là dessus ces
élus ont été alertés sur ce risque dix
ans
l'idée est séduisante mais si jamais
vous héberger une femme victime de
violence dans cet endroit là le conjoint
violent saura où la trouver plus
facilement pourra venir éventuellement
l'agressé voix attenté à ses jours donc
il ya une réflexion et lorsque je
rencontre des élus ruraux sur le
territoire ils me disent quelles
solutions vous pouvez nous proposer en
la matière parce qu'effectivement
l'éloignement ne satisfait pas et le
fait de ne pas avoir une structure
dédiée à l'échelle intercommunale ou à
l'échelle du territoire nous manque
comment on peut être accompagné nous
sommes des petites communes avec peu de
moyens
mais ne nous résignons pas à laisser des
femmes en détresse dans cette situation
là à savoir pas de propositions
protectrice et fonctionnel sur nos
territoires vous avez le sujet des
violences dans le monde rural et c'est
un sujet que nous avons identifiés parce
que souvent il ya une voie là il ya un
manque de services publics qui fait que
c'est encore plus compliqué il ya le
fait que tout le monde connaît tout le
monde il yal isolement les problèmes de
mobilité nous l'avons déjà identifiés et
c'est moi j'ai c'est pour ça qu'on a
travaillé sur les dispositifs associatif
qui peuvent exister parce que là pour le
fou le aller vers et l'être le plus
proche c'est la clé la plus importante
et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs avec
joël giraud nous avons annoncé et bien
justement au congrès dé voilà que nous
allions faire un appel à projets on va
mettre à disposition un million d'euros
pour accompagner toutes les associations
qui travaillent soit sur les questions
des violences intra familiales soit pour
celles qui ont des projets de 2
pour les projets économiques créer une
entreprise et d une entreprise à se
développer et c est moi je suis prête à
regarder toutes les propositions
cliquer que vous pourriez avoir toutes
les idées que vous pourriez avoir pour
aller auprès de ces femmes et on a par
exemple aussi augmenter les subventions
aux et vars et au cidff justement pour
améliorer le maillage territorial et
éviter qu'ils aient tous ces trous dans
la raquette et on a financé aussi des
dispositifs comme les bus itinérant je
sais pas si vous en avez entendu parler
parce que c'était aussi pour rompre avec
cet isolement et faire en sorte que
bien si ces femmes ne peuvent pas venir
à nous que nous nous allions à elle et
je conteste je constate aussi qu'il ya
une forte coopération entre les acteurs
locaux et à chaque fois que nos services
nous parle de ses difficultés je leur
demande de trouver une solution locale
pas de compter sur les se met vraiment
de nous proposer quelque chose et ça
nous permet aussi de voir où il y a des
trous dans la raquette si vous me
permettez cette expression très
familière
je vais vous avouer quelque chose mais
peut-être que vous l'aviez déjà
identifiés dans l'agenda rural la
question des femmes avaient été oubliés
ça en dit long sur d'où nous venons et
tout ce qui nous reste encore à faire et
c'est pour ça que vraiment moi je serais
très heureuse si monsieur le sénateur
vous avez déjà et vous toutes et tous
ici si vous avez des idées plus
spécifique de choses que nous pourrions
faire moi j'y serai extrêmement
attentive
monsieur le sénateur arnaud où va
l'argent
c'est une excellent je peux quand je
disais tout à l'heure que nous avons
utilisé 98 % de notre budget nous
l'avons nous l'avons bien utilisé pour
les personnes qui sont victimes de
violence maintenant peut-être que ça
n'est pas aussi visible que que
que cela pour tout le monde et je vais
vous dire plusieurs choses d'abord on a
fait une expérimentation qui a été
lancée sur je vais je vais d'abord
parler des questions d'hébergement parce
que sont assez essentiel il ya une
expérimentation qui a été lancé lors du
premier confirmant avec le groupe sos on
a mis en place une plate forme de
solutions d'hébergement qui permet en
fait de savoir où il y a des places
disponibles et
plutôt que ce soit les femmes qui
partent comme souvent ça arrive et bien
que ce soient les auteurs de violence
qu'ils soient
qui quitte le domicile et que les femmes
et les enfants restent sur place alors
bien sûr c'est une décision qui doit
être prononcé par le juge aussi c'est
quelque chose d'assez nouveau donc tout
le monde ne s'en est pas encore
complètement emparer mais c'est quelque
chose qui commence maintenant à rentrer
dans les moeurs donner la possibilité
aux femmes de rester quand elles le
veulent et donner la possibilité que ce
soit les hommes qui partent quand c'est
un choix parce que beaucoup de femmes ne
veulent pas partir et ça c'est on en
vient à la question de l'emprise mais en
tout cas leur donner la possibilité de
choisir et cette solution justement elle
permet aux victimes
de faire un cheminement quand elles sont
souvent prises et qu'elle ne décide pas
de partir et bien que le juge puisse
prononcer l'éviction du conjoint violent
ça aide énormément et cette
expérimentation est là on l'a évidemment
pérenniser après la période de
confinement quand on a vu qu'elle
qu'elle finançait bien et on a aussi
décidé de financer une ligne qui
s'appelle ne frappait pas qui est une
ligne lorsqu'on sent la violence monte
et bien que les auteurs de violences
puis ça prend appelé cette ligne et
avoir un accompagnement si je puis dire
psychologique pour éviter qu'on en
arrive à des situations dramatiques et
c'est la fnac av je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez cette structure c'est la
fnaca ve qui s'occupe de cette ligne et
qui prend en charge les auteurs
vous les avez reçu d'accord où va
l'argent il est aussi allé
sur les centres de prise en charge des
auteurs de violences parce que c'est des
structures qui n'existait pas du tout
jusque maintenant et je rappelle qu'on
en a créé plus de 20 l'année dernière et
que on en aura une trentaine d'ici la
fin de l'année où va l'argent il est
allé aussi dans la création du 39 19
dans les pas dans la création mais dans
l'extension de la ligne du 39 19 et où
va l'argent il va dans le soutien des
associations qui sont têtes de réseaux
comme la fédération nationale se dire
solidarité femmes mais pas que il ya
beaucoup d'autres associations mais si
vous me posez la question c'est
peut-être que nous devrions être plus
clair et plus transparent sur sur ce
sujet là parce que
parce qu'encore une fois on ne laisse
aucun euros de côté et
s'il y a si vous souhaitez que nous le
croisions davantage et que nous vous
donnions davantage de détails nous nous
tenons évidemment à votre à votre
disposition et sa figurera de quoi qu'il
en soit dans le document de politique
transversale où vous verrez chaque ligne
de l'utilisation de ce budget
des cris
à dix on l'a dit peut-être un peu trop
déconcentré vers le niveau régional mais
qu'on puisse avant et il ya des années
des opérations concrètes des réponses et
des financements d'appels à projets dans
les territoires ce qui nous permettrait
d'ailleurs d'avoir une sorte de
compilation des expériences et peut-être
des retours d'expérience qui peuvent
être d'ailleurs dupliqué dans d'autres
territoires donc là d'une gestion je le
prends je prends ce point là et je vais
regarder avec nos équipes comment nous
pouvons vous fournir sur la je vais
venir maintenant le monsieur le sénateur
sur la question de des pensions
alimentaires elle est importante parce
que on sait aujourd'hui que dans notre
pays 30 % des pensions alimentaires ne
sont pas payés où elles sont payés de
manière parcellaire et c'est toujours
très compliqué et très irrégulier et et
pourtant c'est un droit parce qu'une
fois que s'est prononcée par la justice
on devrait pas avoir à courir après cela
mais rappelons que pour les familles
monoparentales les pensions alimentaires
c'est pas loin en c'est entre 18 et 20%
du budget donc quand ça n'est pas payé
c'est extrêmement difficile et c'est
pour cette raison que suite à l'annoncé
qui a été faite le président de la
république olivier ferrand et adrien
taquet ont mis en place ce service des
pensions alimentaires et depuis le 1er
janvier 2021 nous avons eu enfin il y a
eu 45 mille demandes qui ont été
déposées auprès de la caisse des
allocations familiales
il y en a dix sept mille cinq cents qui
ont été intermédié et 11500 qui
reçoivent l'allocation de soutien
familial et vous avez raison ça naît ça
n'a pas pris autant de manière aussi
importante que nous l'aurions souhaité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on veut
aller plus loin et on va systématiser le
paiement par la caisse d'allocations
familiales de ces pensions alimentaires
dans le futur pfs
qu'est ce que j'ai dit plfss j'ai oublié
un ace
est ce qu'il y avait oui oui il y avait
la question de madame la sénatrice
patricia des miles à l'heure moi je
crois que la question de la formation
est évidemment absolument crucial et je
me rends compte d'ailleurs y compris
dans les métiers où on aurait pu penser
qu' il y avait un certain savoir faire
une certaine connaissance compris dans
les métiers comme la santé dans les
métiers fondamentaux
il y a aujourd'hui une défaillance et et
c'est pour ça que en lien avec le centre
hubertine auclert nous avons décidé de
travailler sur des modules de formation
qui vont aller vers les élus sur
différentes thématiques sur les
questions des violences sur l'égalité
économique et sur la culture de
l'égalité et
je suis désolé de vous le dire et je le
dis en même temps avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'humains du d'humilité
que ce soit dans l'éducation que ce soit
dans la santé que ce soit dans le sport
enfin dans beaucoup de secteurs la
culture de l'égalité aujourd'hui
n'existe pas c'est pour ça aussi
d'ailleurs qu'on a décidé de renforcer
le travail de
me profs dont aujourd'hui le travail le
plus important qui se fait c'est sur la
formation des professionnels quand on
dit qu'il faut augmenter le nombre
d'ordonnancés de protection si les
avocats ne le savent pas s'ils ne les
requiert pas eh ben on n'avance pas donc
nous sommes on parlait aussi tout à
l'heure de la justice il ya eu
énormément énormément de formation qui
ont été faites à destination des métiers
de la justice pour coups il ya une prise
de conscience sur ces sujets qui
n'existaient pas et donc il faut former
et équiper les personnes qui en sont
responsables pour qu'elles puissent
correctement faire leur travail et puis
en ce qui concerne madame la sénatrice
la situation des femmes rurales
évidemment il ya des dispositifs qui
sont mis en place pour
l'insertion professionnelle et pour
notamment les aider dans la création de
l'emploi de leur entreprise elles sont
financées aujourd'hui par notre
ministère demain elles vont être aussi
être financés par le ministère
de jacqueline gourault et que je vous le
disais tout à l'heure avec joël
giraud nous avons lancé cet appel à
projets il concerne à la fois les
violences mais également l'émancipation
économique et
on a également travaillé avec bpi france
et les différents cidff avec pour
objectif de favoriser pas favorisés
parce que je pars faire penser que
davantage favorisé une mais on s'est
rendu compte que le financement des
entreprises portées par les femmes
étaient très très très souvent
[Musique]
défaillant en comparaison avec les
entreprises créées par des hommes c'est
une vérité factuellement les chiffres
prouvent que les fonds d'investissement
par exemple il n'y a que 3 % des fonds
d'investissement les plus importants en
france qui investit sur les entreprises
créées par les femmes alors même que
l'on sait que ces entreprises sont aussi
performante aussi résiliente et donc là
aussi il ya un biais discriminant sur
lequel nous travaillons avec babe avec
la bpi et avec le cidff est par ailleurs
on a parce qu'on avait identifiées cette
difficulté on a décidé de créer
un guide de l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
entre guillemets que nous avons mises à
disposition des femmes et on a également
des réseaux professionnels pour les
femmes qui comme celui que vous
connaissez certainement femmes et
territoires avec lesquels nous
travaillons et nous avons décidé de les
subventionner aussi parce qu'elles font
un travail absolument remarquable
ce que ye s'il ya une chose sur
lesquelles on est d'accord c'est que le
travail effectivement des associations
sur ces questions là est absolument
indispensable et très important et
et nous avons financé dans un appel à
projets avec femme et territoires un
sujet de
d'autonomisation
économique qui semble-t-il fonctionne
plutôt bien aujourd'hui
[Musique]